so I want to show you one of the best
shakes for the liver to actually to
clean the liver okay this is liver
cleansing on steroids okay so we have
three different vegetables we have the
kale and by the way I freeze all of
these vegetables they last forever stick
them right in the icebox freeze them so
we got kale
we have beet tops okay cut the tops of
the beets I freeze them beet tops have
1300 milligrams of potassium per cup
this is 500 milligrams so it has a mass
amounts of potassium it's good for the
liver gallbladder a lot of iron okay
then we have parsley it's frozen
okay the parsley is way higher than
vitamin A then the kale so it has
tremendous about a vitamin A magnesium
zinc it has potassium very very bitter
so all these are very bitter so I put
mainly kale some beet tops and parsley
and I fill it up almost to the top with
water but it's floating so it's kind of
going over so I'm going to blend this
now here's the problem this is very hard
to drink so we're going to have to
offset that bitterness with we have to
camouflage it with something a little
bit sweeter now if your metabolism is
slow okay then you might want to use
this liquid stevia it's berry flavored
liquid stevia okay so some people don't
like the taste the stevia so but if you
do this would be a good like 10 drops
okay the other option is the kale shake
berry flavored put a scoop in there and
it won't taste bitter anymore it takes
that bitterness out so this is good but
for the average person that has an okay
metabolism or for kids and things you
can use a little bit of berry eye
blueberry and strawberries frozen I'll
put those in here and I'm going to blend
this so you can see the color is brown
because you're mixing green and red from
the beets okay so we're going to take
that talk about enzyme rich
okay so this is what I do I'll drink all
down one of these and I'll do another
one in the day don't drink this before
you go to bed
it'll you'll be up peeing it's it's like
a diuretic so much potassium I also use
everyday I use the cruciferous food as
well now this has a spectrum of organic
beets Brussels parsley kale it has
cabbage radish garlic tumeric seek help
so this has all organic vegetables too
like regular vitamins are all synthetic
chemicals this is like a real vitamin
three of these a day will give you a
tremendous amount of nutrition but it
has the final nutrient effect so I'll do
three of these in addition to this so it
gives you a healthy glow it gives you a
lot of energy mental clarity you just
have you wake up and you feel bright in
the morning so definitely go ahead and
start using this combination keep in the
freezer and go ahead and subscribe to my
channel and make your comments below
I'll see you the next video